tutti ragazzi è venuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo tornati
sui volevo prima di cominciare a
ringraziare moltissimi di voi
dopo il primo episodio mi hanno
consigliato una traduzione per il che
primi venti ragazzi prima giochiamo
gioco in inglese adesso in italiano
non è che non che ci fossero problemi
però diciamo che così fosse più c'è
diciamo più bello da giocare dato che
tutto in italiano si capisce si capisce
meglio tra l'altro è fatto benissimo
quindi complimenti a chi ha fatto la
produzione di legna dell'avanti dove ci
eravamo fermati ce la sta bella tizia lo
so che mi stai guardando con questo
sguardo molto sexy all'italiana non ne
voglio scappare oakley perché sarò
questionari portavo quindi a posto prego
avanti ma che cazzo c'era questa busta
priva di uccideva a meno è stata gentile
poverina vaso pieno d'acqua mentire a me
giletti rosa blu la rosa due tornate in
salute perfetto che cazzo ci compare
costa rovato quali sotto un team a fare
movimenti spazi c
buongiorno senta ci sono negozio è
figlio si è svegliato ovviamente il
dolore è sparito a te come cazzo è
sparito che ne so ha detto che ci sono
le gocce io non so che cosa sia cannata
ma io me ne vado aspetta non è che sei
qualcuno della galleria da 6 a grazie al
cielo c'è qualcuno qui a parte me sa che
anche questo e un disperso
buongiorno sia una scheda semi non si
capisce di che sesso è sto tizio capisco
neanche idea di come siano arrivate qui
e di come siamo arrivati a questo punto
sembra che siamo finiti situazioni molto
simili devo dire che vedevo di essere
spacciato grazie perché mi ha riportato
a caio maschio abbiamo capito o un
ermafrodita non lo so comunque ora
innanzitutto faremmo meglio ri trovare
un'uscita io mi chiamo garry e tu chi
sei
i libici non possa lasciare una ragazza
gironzolare in un posto così pericoloso
verrà anch'io contenuti grate c'era chi
quel discutano
io io l'ho detto calmo è soltanto sputo
mi sono un po spaventato davvero eco
tutto si non guarda il coraggio io sono
per molto meno
comunque anche potenziare quelle cose
bizzarre ragazzi noi andiamo chi se ne
fotte andiamo cos'è sta roba era stata
senza testa né l'ho dimenticato vai
che brutto posto per questa cosa mio dio
ma che cosa fanno le gocce ragazzi ma
peggiore gli spinaci
ora possiamo procedere va bene andiamo
ragazzi io avessi davanti mangio
gocciole lo dico l'atmosfera si fa
sempre più bella ragazzi non vedo l'ora
di andare avanti cos'è sta roba
un labirinto che beh mi oddio ragazzi
sotto c'è stato uno scritta ti piacciono
i labirinti ma guarda sinceramente
preferirei giocare a carte ma non
importa andiamo avanti così che cazzo
sono ste cazzo a terra poiché prodotte
c'è quella roba cos'è controlla
direttamente a sud della vernice rossa
direttamente a sud dell'acqua a sud c'è
un interruttore sul muro attivarlo
attivato
ha fatto c'è stato un suono fuori o che
hanno spesso attivato qualcosa mi sto
brani stupro che è perfetto mi ha quasi
stuprato del tutto sono vivo però ho
attivato qualcosa di fuori non so cosa
sfilate menti rosa sono vivo perfetto
ragazzi ricordatevi che se ci sono dei
manichini in un labirinto non lasciatemi
mettere all'angolo perché potrebbero
stuprarmi cos'è sta roba è quello che
schifo è perché ci sono occhi per terra
guarda amico via mi sto facendo delle
domande da più tempo di te dato questo
qua amica mi sa che ha guardato troppo
televisione questo occhietto ha un
problema di congestione non lo so magari
mettici le cose non lo so amico mio non
me ne frega niente sinceramente andiamo
avanti c'è un buco nell'occhio del
serpente fantastico ragazzino nun so che
cazzo mi possa servire ma noi andiamo
avanti
devo si sposta mentale ragazzi va bene
non o peggio a vita deve arrivare ma
cazzo ragazzi che casa fatto non sono
anche allora io non ci sarei mai più di
arrivare ottenute le gocce per occhi ma
veramente c'erano le gocce ma io io ho
sparato completamente accardo e c'erano
veramente io io direi che un pochettino
di gocce ci stanno bene sull'occhio
comunque ragazzi usa gocce per occhi
ok perfetto la congestione è stata
curata fantastico delle signore ti
faccio l'oculista 2 cazzola l'occhio a
cui dato le gocce e fissa intensamente
il muro si vede che quelle corse ma
andavano tanto bene che cazzo trovato un
passaggio segreto nel muro o c'è
qualcosa per terra ottenuta la palla di
vetro nostro ok controllate sto trovando
di tutto
in mezzo secondo lo so che cazzo passato
i ragazzi non chiedetemi come cazzo sto
facendo ma sto risolvendo di tutto
in mezzo secondo cena scritti c'è una
scritta dietro la cornice dietro il
grande albero azzurro gasquet che albero
che albero vuoi che ne so io io io vado
avanti lo stesso c'è una poltrona sofà
di vino amico mi è normalissimo stessi
specie alla luce perché questi non
pagano le bollette sensazioni una
scultura di un albero che somiglia
veramente una persona
c'era scritto dietro al velo ma non c'è
un cazzo di niente ciò che cosa non
trova la stratega clicco ecco perfetto
trovato non è per caso una fede nuziale
che ci fa in un posto come questo non lo
so ma meno male che ho trovato è dato
bellissime strutture complimenti a chi
l'ha fatta e che cazzo me ne faccio li
sta roba
devo allora fermi in atti un contratto
una fede nunziale non so che cazzoni può
servire
buongiorno pioli fiori sono belli grazie
d'amico il fiorellino e ti farò passare
dai la rosa rosso che perfetto dal
doloroso rossa aspetta il ne seguiamo
sicuro non mi fiderei di questa cosa non
so che cazzo a trovare quindi va bene
passata la rosa tanto lo so che muoio lo
so lo so già
bene ora è ora
[Musica]
forse con l'anello ci sono sigle tizia
non è che devo mettere tipo l'anello al
dito della scuola possibilmente della
scuola mano sinistra della sposa è in
lutto
metti l'anello d'argento mettila nel
loro argento dove indici media non aree
mignolo cellulare l'anello si mette qui
poi io non l'ho non so se è giusto messo
l'anello sull'anulare che cazzo lo
prendo io lo prendo io lo so che lo
volevano tutti i buchi sul cane l'ho
preso io
ora propri sto mazzo di rose però se io
primato dato alla rosa adesso tp il menu
intero da il bouquet è perfetto ha un
buon profumo per magna magna mancate
tutto gradi con troppa vj vai perfetto
sono 50 euro più iva
grazie grazie mille come promesso puoi
passare entra inter in questa porta vga
una porta diventato ma poi è il quadro
porta perfetto ragazzi siamo scatola
sbilanciata ragazzi che cazzo stiamo
andando
ma quando lo stand termina la faccia
figli io qua vi sto pagando già addosso
non so che cosa sta per succedere che
minchia là di questo non c'è neanche gli
occhi quindi va ventato le teste erano
fantastiche complimenti andiamo avanti
perché ero lì da lì che cazzo stia per
succedere ma casa la sala veloce se si
stacca uno di questi modonna allora qua
non posso cliccare qui non posso tornare
almeno non torna no no no aspettate che
devo scappare gli indicò sawai una
statua senza testa ragazzi dove cazzo
che non ci sarà una porta che si apre
quanti quadri di donne ci sono in questa
stanza
14 o azzeccato ma caso non ci però non
ci posso credere a caso su chi cazzo sei
otto o io io non ho fatto un cazzo
allora io per questo io non vanno andava
in musei da piccolo c'era un motivo c'e
la mente non ho capito che cosa ci
dovrei fare con quelle lettere ma c'è
quella tizia inserisci password che
questa questa mista che non l'attacco
cioè ci provo a caso non succede questa
questa è un po più difficile cos'è sta
roba
l'uomo ha preso per sias ispeziona la
madonna che bello
amico mio sei sette ragazzi comunque ci
sono le gocciola ricche per te ragazzi
ok si spaventi sei tranquillo stai
tranquillo influenze neve si era 56 due
nuove ragazze ok c'è stato un suono
entra veloce ritrae un vaso su un tavolo
a c'è il segno a terna perfetto qui qui
ci siamo
ho sbloccato qualcosa non so cosa ma va
bene così ragazzi buongiorno senta lei
non c'era prima sono sbagli una testa di
manichino
ma prima era qui questa cosa non credo
che ci fosse non era qui i fatti non è
una cosa
molto tranquilla ma non importa andiamo
via natola che ho sbloccato qualcosa ma
non ho ancora capito a perfetto questa
c'è uno specchio sostanza non mi piace
che non c'è un cazzo da cosa si è rotto
ogni tanto sento rompersi qualcosa non
si sa perché
mastica anzitutto sognava ragazzi ma è
normale che sia così no ma ragazzino
allora amico mio io e te dobbiamo farci
la chiacchierata come si deve
una testa di manichino cosa andiamo qual
è entrato nella stanza loro sono anch'io
allora il problema è uno devi toglierti
dal pazzo facciamo così giochiamo a uno
due tre stella ok io guardo lo specchio
ok adesso ti vedo adesso mi giro mi giro
stella perfetto ea volte ho preso ti ho
preso dei gol che cos'è quella è una
testa è una testa normale tira tira le
un calcio bravo vai gerry judah 1
ragazzi si è rotta il 1000 perfetto vedi
solo manichino andiamo ai 208 ceppi
niente perfetto allora cosa devo fare
una testa di chiodi manichino frantumata
sicuro che doveva andare così mi
sembrava mi sembra tutto più facile
sinceramente
ok forse forse non doveva andare così ma
la cosa si sta facendo alquanto cook
perché quella è caduta ma perché si
stanno staccando pian piano tutti quanti
che qualcosa per terra è tenuta la
chiave della la chiave grigia ragazzi mi
stanno veramente scassando le battaglie
ti dai [ __ ] devo passare ragazzi non
servi vista si stanno staccando tutti i
quadri non capito bene ok
stai attentissimo garrick non credo che
ci sia qualcosa qui andiamocene ora cosa
c'è scritto uno dei mastri distillatori
ha danneggiato una delle esposizioni
cielo trovate segnalatelo subito mancano
alcune lettere il poster può essere
tolto dal muro o tiralo bis c'è una
scritta sul muro galli geri appeso
ragazzo io non ho fatto niente scritto
carrey e nonni le mille veri dalle palle
prima che la situazione vada vada a
peggiorare se già non è delle migliori
non è che serve ad aprire questa vero
che chiave grigia perfetto devo fare
intanto sto divano è bellissimo ragazzi
ho visto una rana prima qua dentro non
so se sono stato io credo che possa
essere spostata dalla spostare a destra
o che indietreggia il spingi ok forse
copre la finestra o beh perfetto non
doveva forse non dovevo fare così che io
sinceramente non lo so la porta mou si
apre cosa se stai scherzando la porta
era aperta
quel suono veniva da fuori ragazzi
qualcosa alla porta ha fatto in seguito
ok ragazzi fuori dai [ __ ] ragazzi
dove devo uscire d'uscire che come
faccio che cazzo è sta roba
ok è spuntato un quadro dando al muro
non è
normale credo io esco da quel buco non
ci esco più dopo il buco porca [ __ ]
ok fermi come sto sì allora qualcuno di
sicuro sarebbe entrata una porta aperta
la porta aperta la [ __ ] oddio anche i
manichini sì ma tanto che vai così orge
ragazzi non voto quando nulla io perché
lo slider piange ragazzi che cazzo sta
succedendo
li ho io non ho toccato non ho fatto
nulla io probabilmente se spostava lo
scaffale dall'altra parte morivo sono
sicuro
dovremmo essere abbastanza lontani si
sicuro gli abbiamo fatto capire di che
pasta siamo fatti e sto cazzo invece
perché i quadri non mi sembrano tanto
tranquilli che c'è non stai bene sta
piangendo
ibra torna tra odio che è successo è
svenuta ragazzi svenuta d'acqua qualcuno
c'ha dello zucchero zia a svegliare ok
ragazzi b sfumata qualcosa sono quasi
convinto
non so perché sta entrando dove cazzo
tra entramble ragazzi ma siamo messi
male se sei fumato qualche buongiorno
big bang aspetto sono sei cercata avevi
sola non fumare che cazzo è che cazzo
siamo buongiorno ip come ti senti ho
avuto un incubo
capisco povera bambina composta dire
essere sorpreso guarderesti nella tasca
il mio cappotto
ma c'è una caramella ragazzi puoi
tenerla mangiala pure non si accettano
caramelle dagli sconosciuti lo dice la
mamma
ripassiamo un altro po qui prima di
ripartire
renga premi il cappotto di lievi perché
sono un poverino c'avrà freddo il mio
cappotto grazie ceramente miei amici a
fezzano facilmente i personaggi ragazzi
maghi harry proprio tanto perché poi mi
sta simpatico e vedevo di un vaso pieno
d'acqua ma mai così dove siamo dove
siamo tra l'altro ma siamo alla fine
della ritrovato la stanza dopo la fine
del corridoio che culo che cazzo siamo
l'uscita e l'uscita bloccata iniziato a
muoversi qualcosa
ragazzi il bottone rosso ok qualcosa mi
dice che sì lo sapevo era quello di
mezzo vaffan cuore
no no gang bang ok ok merda aiuto a dei
ragazzini che possiamo concludere
episodio io lo dico già ragazzi sto
gioco mi piace un casino
mi sta prendendo troppo comunque spero
sia lo stesso per voi perché per me è
fantastico non so perché i ragazzi miei
che possono concludere qui l'episodio se
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
un commento mi piace anche l'afasia di
facebook come non i video trovate nella
descrizione cesaris iscrivetevi che ci
vediamo il prossimo vito bei ragazzi
[Musica]